yesterday I have a fever I was very sick
but I wouldn't miss this for the world
yeah I am today because I feel a great
kinship with this award and with the
people it honors no matter what name is
in this envelope and I had not kicked of
Santa fulfillment I want to be here at
this very moment because each of the
nominees in this category tonight has
made passionate personal films and all
of them will leave tonight with those
films untouched they will be the same
the very same films they were when we
all walked in into the ceremony and for
that you can be very proud
[Applause]
here are the nominees for achievement in
directing Spike Lee Black Lantern pathi
pathi Koski
Jurgis lanthum us the favorite Alfonso
Cuaron Roma at a McKay vice
and the Oscar goes to his name I can't
pronounce Alfonso cuarón
the fourth Oscar for Alfonso Cuaron his
second win tonight
[Laughter]
[Music]
thank you so much being here doesn't get
old I walked by Guillermo doesn't get
old I want to thank so many people
obviously jellied supper issue and
Modena tobira they are the film they are
truly the film amazing cast and crew
Gabrielle Arruda Gabriella Rodriguez and
Nicolas Ellen my producers David Lindy
and Jonathan King participant media
that's around us a Scott Stuber and
Julie Fontaine Netflix Kelly Bush and
vivillon I deem and Guillermo del Toro
Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu and Henry
Holmes now he I have to say I'm going to
get lost in a Bermuda Triangle here so I
better take my notes oh yeah I want to
thank the Academy for recognizing a film
center around an indigenous woman one of
the seventy million domestic workers in
the world without works with a work
rights a character that historically had
been relegated in the background in
cinema as artists our job is to look
where others don't this responsibility
becomes much more important in terms
when we are being encouraged to look
away
muchas gracias Olivo muchos de mi
familia muchas gracias Mexico
y sobre todo muchas gracias por nada y
amor
gracias
[Music]